Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dennis from Newark.
Dennis, what is happening in beautiful Newark,
New Jersey, today?
Speaker 2:
Hi, David. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Wonderful. You know,
things in Newark aren't too great.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: In in New Jersey in general,
you know, things could be better. But
I'm having some really deep concerns
about the state and not necessarily the state
of democracy, but just the state of politics.
And that's because there's an idea that I want to
propose to you. Okay. It seems like. The the shift
of the political spectrum to the right is giving
the, quote unquote, liberal media. So, say MSNBC,
some voices, some Republican or former
Republican voices like Tara Setmayer.
Sure. Michael Singleton, who I believe are very
thoughtful. But this is, in effect, training
liberals, you know, actual liberals
and people left of of liberal
to view neo liberalism as an hour or two, view
neo liberals as allies against neo fascist. Okay.
I think that's really dangerous. And it's
it's just going to bite us in the butt
because we tried that in the 2016 election with
Hillary Clinton. It failed. And and so but but
the establishment just can't afford to push us
further to the left or to or let the left lead
because they've sold out corporations.
Speaker 1: You know, so let me see if I
understand. And Dennis, if there is a
question coming, that would be great.
Your position is that the center left media, like
MSNBC, is proposing neo liberalism as a solution
to the MAGA neofascism, that that's already
failed and that it's not a good path forward.
Speaker 2: That's right. Exactly.
Speaker 1: Well, I agree with that.
Speaker 2: It's. But what I'm asking you is. Yes,
I hope I. This is paralyzing because it's I mean,
Ana Navarro, who's a moderate Republican,
correct? Yes. Is someone whom I very much admire.
And, you know, she. But even though she's a
conservative, she's now a liberal in the view
of how well, she's anti-Trump.
Speaker 1: She's anti-Trump. Dennis,
listen, I hate to do Sue, is there a question
because I have so many people wanting to talk
to me and we are trying to take questions today.
Speaker 2: Yes, I'm I'm sorry, David, I I'm just
I think my question is.
Speaker 1:
Dennis. Thank you. I'm going to I'm going to go.
Okay. We've got to we've got to move on. Just
completely unable to speak.
They're so overcome with emotion.